yeah i mean london's become very bougie
i like i called an uber like it was like
my first uber in london yeah and uh
[ __ ] tesla shows up
and i was just like this is an uber
right i just called an uber yeah a
[ __ ] tesla shows up and like i i'd
never ridden in a tesla before right uh
have you guys ever ridden in a tesla
yeah i haven't uh yeah so like i didn't
know
how they worked because the first thing
you normally go when you go to a car is
you go and you pull the handle right so
i go up to this tesla
and there's no handle it's it's
literally just like it's literally kind
of like a flat kind of handle police
yeah
so i didn't know you were meant to like
just push it in and the handle comes out
i was just like i was like daddy elon
has designed some like [ __ ]
futuristic like travel to mars [ __ ]
[ __ ] stuff it's probably electric so
i'm standing there in front of tesla
like thinking it's like an automatic
door going
[Music]
where is it
was it fun though writing on a tesla it
was very fun yeah it was uh it's a toy
it's like a toy because it's like so
futuristic really it is it is i'm
excited yeah it was it was weird like
seeing
you know seeing like the pad at the
front just completely track everyone
yeah all the cars but like when it came
to pedestrians it was just like [ __ ]
freaking the [ __ ] out because there's so
many pedestrians in london yeah
so it would you know just just seeing it
like just like humans appeared and
disappeared and like this dog was a dog
was a human that it wasn't and but like
it was it was very cool it is very much
a toy um i know like um our mate's
parents owns one as well
never shuts up about it never shuts up
about it he drives it and he's like oh
my mum bought it though he doesn't
mention that he says my tesla ah tesla
oh tesla
yeah because uh he took you on plenty of
uh yeah
yeah yeah i got [ __ ] in the car i'll
tell you about that remember that you
want more [ __ ] in the car remember have
we told out oh no i haven't have we
talked about that on trash chase
driving in this tesla in the countryside
yeah
you know and the tesla actually had been
sitting there all day i had the window
down yeah
and uh i can't remember exactly what
happened but it was like we were driving
along this really country road
and then
oh no i remember what happened we're
driving along this country road it's
kind of dirt road it's you know it's not
the cleanest where we're going and then
he's trying to show off that it can go
like nor to 60 and like you know yeah as
every car owner does they have to prove
that the car is fast yeah as if normal
cars don't go fast
so we're going fast and as he speeds up
there's like uh like i don't know if
it's a comp like a harvester or
something plowing the fields next to us
i no it's the machine that spreads
manure oh okay yeah so as it's spreading
it we're going by and then before i
don't know i'm like chilling like this
in the car and then suddenly just a
[ __ ] wave of manure starts hitting my
it's face into this tesla
and then
everyone is doing that thing of course
like oh
oh god oh god
and then there's just [ __ ] everywhere it
is tesla and he just got it cleaned and
it's it's like white seats as well
that's right
white seed tesla and the inside is pure
white absolutely like [ __ ] white oh
my god you should never have your
interior this color for this reason
and so there's just oh god and so the
entire car journey it just smells of cow
[ __ ]
it just absolutely reeks of cow [ __ ] and
he's freaking out because it's his
parents tesla and he's borrowing it so
he's like he's
oh what like
i gonna do oh
it's like freaking out yeah i'm like
don't worry we're gonna clean it's gonna
clean
oh my god my parents gonna kill me
so anyway about that
and there's like
like chunks like this big of manure in
the car
and it's just it's and the smell is just
everywhere oh my god so we go into that
we go into like a pizza express
afterwards and we just stink of [ __ ]
we're just eating pizza
and then i think he goes to get it they
must have been so confused because like
the people working there is just like a
bunch of dudes just smelling like [ __ ]
eating pizza they're like oh man they
[ __ ] live like this meanwhile they
head back into this
i think he got it cleaned like the next
day or the day off because he was so
angry yeah i have to get it
so you're gonna think yeah because i
remember even like
him like building up that he's like oh
my god my parents let me borrow the
tesla guys i'm driving the tesla i'm
driving the tesla and it was just like
this this massive event in our friend
group that like eugene's coming in a
[ __ ] tesla damn day after connor's
like guys i got [ __ ] eugene's tesla
yes we're going to country
why people want to do this but i just
want to put my arm like this yeah of
course of course
and so yeah then uh obviously i couldn't
have predicted that a bunch of manure is
going to fly on the carpet yeah
i did
but it was so funny at his anger that
his tesla was covered
i wasn't too bothered about being
covered in [ __ ] yeah yeah it wasn't like
i was going to like a formal dinner or
something right yeah yeah
get drunk
i was like whatever
i'll just clean it i'll clean the
clothes yeah that's so funny yeah it was
good